beaucoup de réactions également
aujourd'hui après la décision de
washington hier de faire évacuer ses
personnels ainsi que les familles
présentes à kiev londres a décidé tout à
l'heure à son tour d'emboîter le pas et
de retirer une partie des effectifs de
son ambassade l'union européenne pour le
moment refusé toujours d'ordonner un tel
retrait n'y a pas de raison dramatiser
déclaré josep borrell pour les
ukrainiens ce retrait est simplement
tout simplement prématurée alors que les
américains estiment que la situation est
devenue critique que le risque d'
invasion russe est lui aussi trop con
crèche